my guest tonight has way too many
credits to list
but in short he's been an executive
producer for top chef queer eye project
runway
and the real housewives franchise he's
also the host
of watch what happens live please
welcome the
king of reality television he denies it
but i insist it's true
andy cohen how are you andy conan i
wanted to ask you first of all
uh kovid i know you had kovid
right um how are you feeling are you
feeling okay
now i feel great i mean you know
my i always have a uh a little bit of an
issue
uh finding names in my head and i don't
know if it's the covet or the mass of
thc that's developed because of uh
the pandemic yeah but uh but i otherwise
feel great
yeah i can't come up with names now i'm
not sure who you are at this moment i'm
fine i'm going in and out all the time
but i just attribute that to
too much mileage too many years too many
pop culture references
and uh i can't come up with names now
the way i used to so and i don't and
that is not covid related
well the great thing about that is since
everyone is communicating
on zoom these days all you have to do is
move your little mouse and then it'll
say i'm like oh yeah that's conan
o'brien like
our names are on the screen it's been
delightful talking to you
andy cohen um i have to ask you this
i know you have a son ben who is i think
around two years old is that right
correct well done um what's it like
you're you're single you're in the
dating world what's it like
dating when you have a two-year-old i
did not experience that
my dating uh life you know ended and
then i had kids
and uh so i never had to balance the two
is it tricky
i actually have not dated
in a very long time just because of the
circumstances that we've been living in
but
before yes it was very weird
because people are like oh so you have a
kid
and then i'm like yeah and then i'm like
look let's look at the nanny cam
and then when they see the nanny cam
it's like it's a little bit of a
it's it's it makes it all very real to
people
right but i think that's in a way i'm
gonna say this i think it's good
because you find out you find out is
this someone
if the person is freaking out about that
then you know right away
you know but if the person's like oh my
god that's amazing you know that so it's
good
you're right have you ever had an
awkward thing where
um you know you're talking to someone
you're interested
and then you realize that you've got
child
you know spit up all over your face and
you realize that you've completely
compromised
no i did i was walking down the street
with
my son the other day and it was like i
was taking him to this diner around the
corner
right um for an early dinner on a sunday
and i didn't feel like bringing his
diaper bag
and i just put a diaper and some wipes
in my pocket and this diaper was like i
didn't realize but it was all coming out
of my pocket on the street
and of course it's when i'm like
checking out this super hot guy as
as you know conan when you're like
cruising a guy on the streets of new
york city
you're telling me there's a hot guy
anywhere around beep
beep beep i can find him i can find
legendary
legendary legendarily well yeah thank
you thank you
yes obviously that's how you met jordan
schlansky right
you produced him that's right that's my
one of our uh producers at the gym we
have an
associate producer on the show jordan
schlansky and there he is
and um jordan schlansky is uh yes that's
how i met
him it turns out he's straight and then
i realized i'm straight
so it never developed into a
relationship oh that's too bad but it
will eventually
you know obviously i've always
you guys have been ripping on him for so
long i wonder
what's holding him back from the full
producer title
uh first of all he does nothing
he does absolutely nothing and you
actually have to do something
to become a full producer he is lucky to
be an associate producer
um it's a total scam and uh
and and that's why he is not progressing
and so
yeah and i always wondered that i guess
like because i think he's in his 40s
he could be in his 50s or 60s we don't
know he is not
moving forward in life but you know
by the way very well preserved he's very
well preserved though
i wanted to pitch you on an idea i know
that you are the king of reality
television and you're a great creator
and producer of reality tv shows what
about a show with jordan
called look at that up
with the schlansky's would that interest
you at all
you know i have to say i find
you know the the poster in the marketing
is enough to get me in the tent
i have to say yeah the problem is he's a
little bit of a flatliner on the air so
i don't know what you are gonna have
it's perfect the idea is that he doesn't
even have a family
you just use digital imagery so it's not
like the kardashians where there's
actually
different distinct human beings sisters
this is
four schlansky's that are digitally
recreated and they all interact with
each other
that's the next level of reality tv you
know what
i think you're right yeah i think i want
to buy that
fta or whatever the hell it's called i
don't know what those initials mean but
it's yours
for 45 million dollars and um or
three hundred dollars i don't care
whatever you have on you i just want him
gone
yes let me ask you something i yes you
have been
extraordinarily successful um yes i'm
going to move on and i'm going to do
something for hbo max
but i'm also thinking i need to broaden
my horizons
maybe i'd get into the world of reality
television i
i i don't think it's too late i think
it's just beginning
and uh one thing i'm curious about is
what's your technique
if you had to boil it down andy to what
has been one of your techniques in
reality tv that has paid off again and
again and again
a little trick a little something you do
that really makes shows work what would
it be
well besides the casting yeah because
really it is about the casting
i think there's something that we call
the bravo wink when we edit the shows
and it's
you know we if someone says i'm crazy
about
fitness and all i do is you know work
out
right you know the the camera might pan
off to the left
and you see an ashtray full of
cigarettes
yeah got it that's kind of the bravo
wink a little bit
i think i understand what you're talking
about andy well
well let me actually make this a little
clearer because if i took you for
example
um well we we brought a little piece of
tape a little uh
tape that might might show you what i'm
talking about
okay now let's take a look let's see on
nights when our guest is here in person
it's got kind of a classy pbs look
a bad rap around california because
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i love you
i feel like i'm jerking off a robot
it all feels very educational and
erudite what do you think andy
that was fantastic i i hey listen
can i ask you a question yeah what was
happening in the clip
of you wearing the mom jeans putting
your ass in that guy's
face that's from comic-con that's from
comic-con and those weren't
mom jeans uh that was a superhero outfit
that was made
by the people that make dc and marvel's
superhero outfits
complete with padding it's the only time
in my life i've had an
ass and i was so happy i was so
thrilled that i kept making people slap
that ass
now tell me about this project i want to
ask you about it you've produced
and hosted a documentary series uh
for real it's the story of reality
television
and this sounds very interesting to me
because it's become such a cultural
touchstone
reality tv it's everywhere and you're
doing something really interesting which
is saying let's really examine this and
see how this developed and how this all
unfolded because there's a whole
generation now that thinks it's always
been here
right your documentary is showing us no
no
this started in a very specific way at a
very specific time
for you what did you realize when you're
doing this documentary what was the
beginning of reality tv for you
for me the beginning of reality tv was
season one of the real world
uh that i think began the modern
wave of reality tv and
uh we this is a seven part series that i
did for e and it's broken each hour is
broken out through different genres
of of reality tv and
uh but yeah i mean i i remember watching
that real world new york season one and
just
my eyes were just popping out of my head
because i just thought it was so
brilliant and that it
seemed like a an infinite world
of possibilities that that they had just
opened up
i think one of the things that people
still don't realize
and this is my take everyone knows that
there's some manipulation going on
but on some of these shows like say a
bachelor there's an incredible amount
of psychological manipulation that they
do
behind the scenes to make people react
as strongly as possible that was one of
the headlines for me because
for us it's usually the manipulation
is really just in the casting we cast
highly emotional funny people who
are willing to share everything on the
camera and let them
go right but um with the bachelor i was
really interested i
interviewed a couple they molly and
jason who both they
they traversed the bachelor and
bachelorette worlds
and they really were so open
about producers telling them oh she's
gonna pick you
she's gonna propose to you and then when
she didn't propose to him
he was obviously gave a huge reaction
because he thought he was about to get
proposed to
and um it just it it
and i i don't know it was just
interesting for me seeing how that
sauce was made over in bachelor nation i
don't know about you but as a i know
you're you're a real world fan i
remembered a big turning point
was real world san francisco the bike
the bike messenger puck and i remembered
what he cracked was
up until that point most people were
trying to be reasonable and occasionally
someone's over tired or there's a fight
or someone has a crush on someone
puck decided i'm gonna blow this thing
up i don't care
and everybody any time puck was on
screen people were like what's he gonna
do now
and i felt like after that um
everybody every season was people were
going into it thinking
oh i got to be the puck i got to be the
guy puck walked so omarosa
could run that's a book i'm working on
it's a very very long book
and i'm devoting all my that's why i'm
that's
temporary that's why i'm winding down
the nightly version because i want to
work very hard on that book
before i go on to my next project some
people are calling it a huge waste of
time and a mistake
i think i'm making the right call wow i
do too yeah i think it's
compelling yeah you're a terrible actor
[Laughter]
oh my god i'm the worst actor on the
planet
i i am the worst actor ever and as a
matter of fact i've been
i was i've been friendly with sarah
jessica parker for many years
and i knew michael patrick king the
great great
michael patrick king writer and director
and he was you know really the creative
energy behind sex in the city and
he but wait long before i was ever on
television
i um he was like i want you to come
audition for a part all right
um on sections and it was
it was the role of this party planner
and i
i they sent me the script and i was
auditioning with my friend john hickey
who's an actor and he was like you are
just
so bad it's just not even possible and
then
i did it for sarah and she was like what
are you
doing and you're improvising and you
have to do what's on the thing i'm like
i wouldn't say this she's like it's not
you
i mean it's anyway so yes there's a
reason there's a reason we're not
character i mean we're not actors
i think i would i can't do anything
where i can't find the camera so i think
if you put me in a movie i'd enter and
say
i love you and i've always loved you
you know it's like cut what are you
doing idiot
i don't know that being said i have
played myself on a
number of shows right and that is a role
that i feel like
i i can kind of play i hope someday
you're cast as yourself and they fire
you and hire an actor
i would i would truly not be surprised
i am so i am that bad
well you're doing something right uh
watch what happens live with andy cohen
air
sunday through thursday nights on bravo
and i'm actually i'm looking forward to
the uh documentary series
uh for real i think that could be i'm
fascinated to see your take on how
this all happened thank you yeah yeah
and um
i look forward to crossing paths with
you soon i can't wait to travel and get
back to new york so
i hope you cruise me on the street i
will cruise you on the street i've got
diapers uh in my pockets but they're for
me
so good because i don't need to be
dealing with anyone's poop but my sons
i have enough to deal with here right
hey andy
thank you very much really nice thank
you again take care